pour que quand ils se reproduisent les
balkany moi je vois c'est que c'est
comme les poissons ils mettent leurs
yeux puis le mât l'arrivée puis il
asperge peu la pression
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un signe que que tu vis
ça c'est le spectacle s'est rué à quand
j'ai commencé à voir des glaces à
prendre 3 34 j'ai vraiment senti que tu
vois je commençais à voir surtout quand
je m'assois et je pense le faire des
courses à faire du bruit d'efforts je
commence à faire des bruits d'efforts
pour me caler ce qui est quand même fou
tu as normalement avant quand tu arrives
tu vois je vais m'allonger hachad là je
lui rends là je vais m'allonger jamais
être bien je suis bien
petite table
puis gueule quand on veut aller chercher
ça alors tu vas
[Musique]
[ __ ] j'en ai aucune idée générale
c'est ma meuf qui me dit bon allez on y
va ouais ouais ouais tout le monde s'est
pas présentée officiellement encore la
deuxième bien
[Musique]
pourquoi ils se reproduisent les balkany
moi je vois c'est que c'est comme les
poissons ils mettent leurs yeux puis le
mât l'arrivée puis il asperge puis a
pris son nom j'ai été animateur pour la
ville de levallois-perret en revanche
quand je suis arrivé à paris de premier
emploi que j'ai eues j'étais animateur à
la ville de levallois et une fois j'ai
fait un atelier sur le parvis de la
mairie de levallois n'en avait un stand
à la concurrence un chamboule tout et à
un moment donné il ya un mois je peux
jouer et je vois patoche patrick balkany
choix
de mon collègue mike leigh je peux le
seuil et ont vu ce coin des crapauds
et il est parti et il a détourné à 500
millions
oui j'ai numéro d'arthur j'ai même les
trois numéros d'arthur
tout mais bon comme du doigt l'argent
peut-être qu'il va vaincre le plus dur
en ouverture je vais appeler arthur
du grand saut vers m'en fais pas ta
mémère fichiers là j'ai vraiment son
numéro je ne me souviens pas que vous
pensiez que c'est un mytho
au père était agent d'entretien il est à
la retraite donc il peint très très bien
mon père il a un top terrible c'est que
comme il est agent d'entretien et qu'il
a faim il est peintre en bâtiment c'est
un vraie formation c'est ça c'est
peintre en bâtiment et il a une
déformation professionnelle c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il rentre dans une pièce
il regarde les murs il fait
un bond mur il a plus qu'à laisser les
murs de ma mère à mon père il ya un tout
de raccord c'est un chazal des murs mon
père ce qui est un peu nul quoi shahzad
tu fais tu écoutes où il a tout le temps
comme ça
je suis allé sur le travail de sur le
lieu de travail de mon père il m'a menée
dans son atelier et après il vient voir
regarde j'ai refait toutes les chambres
et montrer le plafond eu une statue
devant c'était michel-ange mais
c'est la base quoi c'est bien
[Musique]
vrai vrai j'étais part belle du tout
j'ai grandi dans un village tout le
monde se connaît ma mère avait son sein
une coiffure mon père avait beaucoup de
bagou donc il connaissait tout le monde
du parent 10 et peu importe si tu as des
bonnes des mauvaises notes je veux
surtout pas qu'on dise que tu es mal
poli ou mal élevés ils m'ont inculqué
bonjour s'il te plait merci au revoir si
tu fais ça quatre trucs déjà c'est bien
donc ça va la base de la vie sont quand
même cool
[Musique]
asmr qui se sait
et ça tranche excuse moi donc 300 milles
vu déjà c'est beaucoup 58 minutes 49e il
reste 58 minutes de vidéo là et c'est à
la fois ça m'énerve à la fois c'est
fascinant ranger 320 stylo par couleur
pour votre sommeil d'accord
allez mon patin alors peinture ou le cal
pas très drôle savent arturo sava et
écoute je suis un interview pour brut et
ils m'ont dit ouais est ce que tu es
capable d'appeler arthur et je suis sûre
il va pas répondre j'ai appelé tap a
répondu
c'est tout tu veux faire quoi qu'est ce
que tu fais tu es sur un concept encore
non mais je suis avec brut la john tu
vois que tu répondes ont été un gars
cool arturo
maintenant ils n'ont pas de doute et ils
t'adorent évidemment tu n'envoies la
bombe est en fait se déjoue pas
[Musique]
et je fais du sport tous les jours
d'ailleurs là j'ai couru 10 km je n'ai
pas pu faire monter rex mais pompey mon
village donc je pense que ce soir en
rentrant vers 23h30 je pense que je vais
me taper une heure et demie de vélo en
plus si j'ai pas fait de sport j'ai
l'impression que je j'ai l'impression
que je me
souviens de la pâte je me sens pas bien
qui a donc aujourd'hui ils mettaient du
temps à se remettre au sport et tout je
lui dis mais fais du cardio cours tu vas
te faire du bien il m'a appelé dit rabat
c'est incroyable je me sens très bien
c'est le 23 mai dans ces faux c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai le jour ah merde chez
rivages parce que moi le 23 mai c'est
l'anniversaire de maurice barthélémy et
de françois fellmann on s'envoie ça tout
où tous les ans ça nous fait marrer mais
c'est la journée mondiale de la tortue
c'est génial mais que je parle d'une de
la tortue dans le nouveau spectacle au
jus une tortue mais
j'ai 150 en eau
assez génial gaba merci de me
l'apprendre
non je n'ai pas menti je ne mens pas je
ne mens pas